foreign
[Music]
Mr Scott our trust your journey wasn't
too unpleasant
first class
the manager of the hotel has requested
the pleasure of your company
welcome to the Continental I
am part of a very old and sacred fabric
instant what am I doing here your
brother stole something from me I don't
know what Frankie is
before Frankie took is
very important to a lot of very
dangerous people if you don't retreat
I'll bring the weight of this whole
institution down on you both
this isn't the kind of thing that we
just walk away from
we kill Cormac taking his damn house and
everything that comes with it a takeover
of the whole hotel how are we supposed
to believe a guy in an ass guy can pull
this off it's a cravat
it's time to Outsource perhaps some of
our guests are available
[Music]
Sharon so you're here for Revenge oh no
this is about Justice
[Music]
and away we go
you thought you could add smart the high
table how foolish of you
[Music]
can you dig it
this is my house kill all these suckers
what I'm asking you to do is not easy
I'm offering you a chance to decide who
you want to be
for the man in the mascot I'm sorry
[Music]